I believe today's the easiest time ever
in the history of mankind to think big
ever I'm talking ever and you'll find
out why by the time you're done watching
this entire video why I believe that I'm
gonna cover things that you can
implement for you to start thinking
bigger than you've ever thought before
and here's why this is my argument what
is difficult is for you and a group of
people to decide to create the pyramid
and Egypt without cranes now that's
difficult to think big that's impossible
some would say what would seem
impossible is for you to invent a
machine that weighs tons and tons of
weight to tell four or five hundred
people at a time go in that machine
right there and fly four thousand miles
it's not going to crash you're going to
be safe and a billion people say okay I
believe you
that's impossible that's difficult to
say I want to think that big or I want
to create the ship it's okay you guys
can you know get on the ship I know we
don't see what's out there your name is
Christopher Christopher go out there and
we don't know what's going to happen
you're going to make it out of wood
because we don't know how to make it out
of metal at that time you go straight
and eventually you're going to get to
maybe another land and you can call it
it's your land while people have been
there that's impossible
that's not thinking big that's
impossible to a lot of people landing on
the moon for the first time it's never
been done we don't even know what's out
there you know what why don't we just go
up there we don't know what's out there
we keep looking through these lenses and
you know Todd it's kind of cool I think
there is something out there
and it's called this and it's called
that let's go check it out
that's difficult today for an
entrepreneur to think big piece of cake
today requires energy requires you know
in the formula requires effort requires
the desire but if you're somebody that's
watching this and Saint Pat I absolutely
want to think big I'm going to cover it
with you here today but before I get
into my points I want to first of all
thank a lot of you guys today's my
birthday and we've said having said
we've had so many people send us gifts
from all over the place I want to thank
you we started off with some strange
what do you call that from our friend
Marc Molina like an exotic dancing grant
what do you call exotic dancing Marc an
exotic dancing Graham you sent to my
headquarters you forelady to come and
sing you know happy birthday to you but
you know I appreciate that
you know I'm not the wolf of life
insurance industry I think he mistake me
for the wolf of wallstreet we got so
many I mean voluma Laurie can start a
balloon business here but um I got here
from John John you send me this year
John an attorney from New York and your
son Andrew Andrew buddy
I love the note you sent you keep
listening to your pops and you keep
learning about what it is to become an
entrepreneur one day in the future we
could possibly vote for you to become a
president
I like this gift you from Armand Tati
yawns Santa you know I'm a center fan my
daughter's name is Santa exactly Sen na
this is how much I love this guy sena
and armand send me a nice little thing
here Sen I appreciate that I'm not going
to go through all of them just kind of
giving you a flavor here James Dean
James Dean if we go to the top it says
dream as if you'll live forever live as
if you'll die today which he did but
that quote is a great quote and I'm
going to leave one of these here that
was funny for me I get shoes sent to me
all the time because of a video I did a
long time ago on how I used to set up
meetings when I was a financial adviser
at Morgan Stanley Dean Witter I would
send a box with a shoe understand not I
have one foot in the door help me get
the second one in and these guys got a
little bit more creative they decided to
send me Air Jordans and I've got to give
them love man this is from Arash Cory
Arash you are the man and you are
creative and I can't wait to get the
second pair of this shoe here but
appreciate all the happy birthday
messages I got on snapchat Instagram
Facebook Twitter thank you for all the
love more and more every time I hear
this message just validates how many
entrepreneurs we have around the world
that's following this content I want to
do something big with their life so
let's get right into the episode on how
to think big as an entrepreneur listen
the usual suspect you'll hear about is
what books associations environment pad
you got to read the right books you're
going to have the right associations
going to have the right environment
absolutely these are the usual suspects
whatever I cover with you does not
discount this you need to do this but
I'm covering things you don't typically
hear you hear about the unusual suspects
then I'll give you plan on at the end
what to do and some things I'll cover
there's going to be a bunch of points I
don't know how many points it is I have
them all here it won't be any in any
specific order you need to take notes
even though it's typed out on my website
but you probably have a lot of questions
you want to ask about this that'll start
dialogue on the bottom okay so let's get
right into it let's get right into it
one of the things is that one of the
things is that I love doing this I look
at everything on thinking big from the
standpoint of math so just let you say
math math has a lot to do with thinking
big let me make my case you know what I
mean by math has a lot to do with
thinking big the way I used to do it was
this I used to ask myself what number
comes after three so if I can make $3 do
you think I can make $4 everybody would
say what of course ok if I can make $100
can I make $200 yes now what are you
going with this if you can make $1000
can you make $2,000 of course if you can
make 10 grand in a month can you make
you 11 grand a month yes yes of course
you can so when does this stop never it
only stops when you no longer are
applying math to thinking big you see
big thinking victim is purely a math
thing no number is an N number if I ask
you right now what's the biggest number
in the world you can't think about a
number because there isn't a number
that's the biggest number in the world a
billion times billion times billion is
still a number that's bigger if you type
give another multiplication times
another billion and that's still not the
biggest number if you go against another
billion and another billion and another
billion there is no number that's a
limit people are going to hit these
numbers billionaires seemed impossible
until somebody became a billionaire
today Elon Musk could be the first guy
that could potentially be a trillionaire
if he goes at the pace that he's going
this is going to happen but you need to
take these big numbers that seem
impossible I'm starting with this first
you need to take numbers that seem
impossible and just know it's numbers
there is nothing to be afraid of numbers
it's purely math what is so big about
numbers
nothing is big about numbers you need to
look at math first period there's always
a math the difference between a small
thinker and a big
is multiplication the big thinker is
multiplying the small thinker is
auditioning his only attic 2 plus 2 plus
2 plus 2 plus 2 is 12 or 10 whatever
that fits 5 is 10 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 times 2 is not 10 is a lot more
than that it's multiplication but it's
math multiplication addition math it's
purely math so start off with whatever
you think seems absolutely big that you
cannot do bring it down to a number look
at it as a number that you haven't done
yet that's all it is it's a number that
you'd be mentioning to get you to do so
number one thing that I like to do is I
look at everything is math I bring you
down make it a smaller bike and I know I
can get the bigger bike but I got to get
a smaller right now based on that next
point next point about how to think
bigger
so whatever the big thinking idea is
that I have whatever the big thinking
idea is that I have I need confidence to
be thinking bigger and confidence
happens with smaller victories okay if
you can have small victories in a game
or in business you eventually start
believing you can have the bigger
victories but a bigger victory doesn't
all of a sudden happen a big victory is
a combination of many many small
victories that didn't stop after another
one you have one victory gonna go get
another one and another one and another
one and another one and another one all
of a sudden you have a massive victory
so you got to have a lot of your small
victories that are taking place together
while you're going at another thing I
would do is say you have a big idea and
you want to do something big so you have
a goal on your business you want to do
something big that's never been done on
your business before test it with five
people and see if you can convince one
of them that believe you very
interesting exercise get five of your
team members you got five salespeople
meet with them individually or in a
group setting or take five of your
employees take your wife your boyfriend
your girlfriend your husband brother
sister mom dad best friend whatever it
is and tell them the idea hey know what
I'm thinking about what are you thinking
about
I'm thinking about doing this this and
one day we're going to do this this and
that and see their reaction on how it is
if you convince them to
you even this much it's possible did
that make sense I don't know if that
made sense try to convince somebody
about the big idea that you haven't
watched their reaction that ought to
tell you a lot for instance I remember
when I had nothing going on I was broke
49 K and dead I had nothing going on I'm
driving a Ford Focus I would go
intentionally to Ferrari dealerships and
you know what I would do I would go to
the car I'd walk in I'd walk in and I'd
walk running the dealership and I'd be
looking at the cars and I wanted to ask
myself can I convince this car salesman
by the way he looks at me does he
believe I can actually be a qualified
buyer and if you go in and nobody comes
talks to you they don't believe you're a
qualified buyer if you go in and they
come and talk you're like you know what
he just acted like he believes I can buy
this maybe I can one day buy this
go to real estate showing where they're
selling three million dollar homes and
walk in and walk around because I'm here
at for this open house great and see if
the listing real estate agent believes
you watch the reaction this is the first
thing they'll do they go like this
they'll come up but forget what you look
like you know what they look like at
your body language at your eyes the way
you walk if you convince them they're
trying to tell you I believe you could
potentially one day on a three million
dollar house that's what they're really
saying to you so take your idea and
share it and pitch it to three to five
other people and see how they react you
if their reaction is believing even if
it's ten twenty percent then it's
possible for you to actually go out
there and hit that you just got to think
bigger right test it out with the people
around you
another one is study people when I say
study people I don't mean by studying
people in a way where everybody says go
study this person go study that person
study what that people with that person
study so for instance don't just study
Michael Jordan study whom Michael
Jordan's study which is David Thompson
don't just study David Thompson study
who David Thompson study can go deeper
in that don't just study you know I used
to study the people that I was looking
at in business in the insurance world
and I would say man what made that guy
special who did he study he
study Teddy Roosevelt he studied coach
Bear Bryant he studied Churchill man let
me see why he studied those people the
salad guy was so strategic he studied
Alexander the Great he studied Darius
he's why did he study those guys oh now
I understand why this guy here him a he
study the Chinese emperors and man what
was he doing studying the China dynasty
and all these guys that built this big
Millington
why was he studying them this other guy
here layering layering out MA why was
Tony Robbins studying this guy why was
you know Reagan studying why was Kennedy
why were these people reading who would
they study it so go deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper nd but what this
does to you is this let me tell what
this does to you it tells you that the
person that you admire now at one point
they doubt it but they studied other
people that injected belief in them to
make them believe that they can be the
person they are another you admire you I
hope I'm making sense I'm not trying to
get too technical go study who they
study and that'll give you a source of
inspiration to know that you can one day
be the person that you're looking at
saying this is impossible for me to be
like this person know you can based on
studying the people that they study let
me continue let me continue
so next point again Paul's going to put
the pause you're putting numbers here so
you're going to put the pond I'm not
putting numbers here next point is this
I believe just like I said earlier to
you and I said this the easiest time
ever to think big I also believe this
the most important time to think big I
said this on a video I've been saying
that on mentions I've been saying it
that I believe 100% of world's problems
are going to be solved by entrepreneurs
I believe that I believe 100% of world's
problems are going to be solved by
entrepreneurs if we keep giving birth to
entrepreneurs entrepreneurs who make it
they have one ability they're problem
solvers they look at something complex
they make it simplify the at five steps
to it you followed you when you make you
can solve cancer you can solve health
issues you can solve you know job
creation you can solve economy
challenges that we're facing in the
world you can solve anything
discrimination anything we have going on
every single prom in the world can we
solve a
one of them our educational system our
political system our you know of oil
challenges we're having anything that we
have can be solved by entrepreneurs so
as you're watching this a lot of times
the first motivation for somebody who's
never been an entrepreneur will say my
man be kind of cool I have a lot of
money to have this job that to have this
that's great there's nothing wrong with
all that stuff
don't let anybody convince you having a
big house having cars and having toys is
not important if you like it you go get
it but it's got to be bigger than that
it's got to be bigger than that you got
to want to do something bigger than that
today know that the world is counting on
you to solve some big problems you can
run your business but know that you got
to figure out a way for your business
that's making a lot of money to also
make a positive impact in the world
social cause positive impact in the
world with you being an entrepreneur
next one imagination big thinkers if
you're ever on big thinkers today we
just had a meeting literally a meeting
right now it was a meeting we had right
now with me you Paul and Tom right and
we're writing stuff on the board all of
a sudden boom Mario says something then
I said something then Paul said
something I think Paul started and Paul
said something and I said well that's a
great idea and then I said something
then Tom said something then Mario said
something and then more you went to the
bathroom and then he came back but then
Tom said something Paul says something
and then it led to a massive idea then I
asked Tom to send an email to a couple
guys that we got to get our call on from
Australia and we're doing a call now
about this massive idea that has to do
with the business that were running
today but it led to him because it was
like what if we can do this now what if
that takes place how about this how
about if we would what if they cost this
much what if we did what if it was this
easy what if it was F as what if this oh
my would have imagine if we could pull
it back that better seed seed seeds and
the roots keep growing keep growing keep
growing and then boom all of a sudden
you get a massive ideas so imagination
especially if it's a group of people
that are also people that are
imagination type of people and that goes
that go so a big thinker is all about
imagination a big thinker is all about
imagination
Nike used to get killed Nike was getting
killed a guy there's a whole complicated
we're behind it some people say it's not
him some people say it's an Italian
mafia guy from New York that that came
to Nike and said the way we're going to
save it is there's a guy that's coming
out of college North Carolina he's the
most incredible basket he's gonna be the
greatest basketball player of all time
he goes to Nike and says let's sign this
guy and give him a half a million dollar
contract what are you talking about we
don't have money I'm telling you forget
all these other chumps you're giving 50
to $100,000 give this one guy half a
million dollars you know look what
happened no and then Michael comes they
talking Michael all he wanted was an
exotic car apparently the negotiation
ended up with them giving him a half a
million dollars for two years or a
million dollars for two years and a
Lamborghini or something - Mike he
signed a contract and then today you
know what this is going to make Mike be
worth in the next 10 15 the numbers
estimated twenty billion dollars in ten
years imagination this guy imagined what
it would happen if we brought MJ to Nike
to solve Nike and 19 dominates everybody
and basketball used to be Reebok
basketball used to be converse magic was
Reebok wasn't magic Reebok converse all
these nobody was looking at Nike as
basketball and then they took off
imagination so you don't necessarily
have to be the entrepreneur by the way
you can be working with an entrepreneur
in a company and you all ourselves and
come up with an idea like this that
takes the business to the next level
you're big thinker you're linked to a
big thinker it wouldn't happen without
you because you're the big thinker right
so imagination next one you got to turn
off the noise you've got to turn off the
noise the noise needs to be turned off
and I'm talking different types of
noises one is too much social media time
with newsfeed it's noise too much I
don't need it too much political stuff
right now you think the big thinkers you
know looking at every single thing about
Hillary Clinton and she's doing this did
you know about you did this and did you
know Trump did this and did you know
that they get bullet points in the
morning when they wake up because
Current Affair you got to know what's
going on with politics it's a country
you're living in but if you go dive into
then you're reading the conspiracy
theory there's I cuss and Alex Jones
then you know Rachel Maddow then all
this other oh my gosh did you see what
Anderson Cooper sent Oh Sean Han you
know ya ain't Billa
you're too much into it that's noise way
too much noise
way too much noise Clinton and Trump are
not going to change your life they're
not they're not going to change your
habits they're not gonna make you better
entrepreneur they're not going to make
you sharper they're not gonna help you
come up with better ideas they're
actually going to consume your mind with
things you shouldn't be thinking about
that's going to piss you off because
regardless who you support you don't
like the other person so the other
person is going to piss you off bounce
stop turn off the noise turn off the
noise of negative friends small thinkers
turn off the noise of family members
that don't support what you want to do
don't even bring up the ideas in front
of them some of them you can't get away
from some of them are your parents some
of them are your brothers and sisters
sibling some of them could be a
boyfriend/girlfriend some of them could
be your spouse some of them could be
your cousin turn it off and if you know
you bring up an idea they're going to go
to negative town do not bring it up in
front of them turn off the noise okay
turn off the noise stop any distractions
any negativity make time to think about
what you could do to think bigger into
business intervention and whatever
company whatever business you're running
as a real estate agent insurance agent
as a technology IT and it doesn't matter
what can you do to think bigger yourself
to be the dominant force in the company
you're a part of in the business you're
a part of in the industry you're part of
what can I do think bigger
right think bigger next one is test the
capacity of an idea what is the capacity
of an idea take out a paper and pen or
board all you need is a board and a
marker or pen on a paper test let the
capacity of the idea okay what would
happen if this happen how big can this
thing get I can get this big how BIG's
the market for this it's pretty big it's
a happy can that market be how big the
market in New York eight point three
million people how big the market in LA
four point two millimeter the market in
Houston three point eight didn't they
just pass Chicago Chicago's on three
point six or something yeah that's a
pretty big market if we go unhappy does
this mark you for this that's it what if
we actually oh you know what if we sell
to this mark you what if we get into
that market what if we got more people
that were doing what if we got more
people to sell the product what if we
got somebody apart what if this person
that team that what if that person
pardon what match capacities pretty good
if we do this but test the capacity what
if I take the semen to a whole different
level
remember Mark Zuckerberg wasn't
necessarily a big thinker
he was a developer a brain a mind the
big thinker where Facebook became who it
is is who what's his name do you know
the name what's the name what's his name
last name Parker
okay so Sean Parker was played by who in
that movie Justin Timberlake Sean
Parker's the Napster guy says and he
says man I feel like we have a million
dollar opportunity Sean says no no this
is a billion dollar opportunity right
and he comes and he sees the capacity
and he says what if we can get into this
what if this is not just universities
what if this is not just colleges what
if the capacity what if we go into
Canada what if we go to your we haven't
you haven't even gone to anywhere yet
what if what if what if and it he's got
a point what if boom today 1.7 billion
users Facebook dominant over everybody
Zuckerberg 50 something Sean's worth a
few billion Edwards worth a few billion
a bunch of people made a bunch of money
and you know it wasn't like it's what a
bunch of people made a lot of money but
everybody was thinking about what can
they do if that's the capacity so
everybody was testing the capacity of
how they can make it bigger and bigger
and bigger group of big thinkers that
said what if we can make this thing even
bigger test the capacity next let the
idea loose let the idea loose a little
bit let it lose the Tasmanian Devil
needs to be let loose at times you can't
lock up a Tasmanian Devil you won't know
his capacity you got to let him loose at
times you got to let a great idea lose
sometimes and see what it leads to it
could take you to places you never
thought you could get to but you got to
let the idea loose of times you got to
let the idea loose at times and you'll
see it spread that's kind of like test
the capacity but let the idea loose so
imagination you know test the capacity
let the idea loose they're all kind of
somewhat together but each one of them I
want to tell you so you kind of
understand the purpose of each one of
them next curiosity ask a lot of
questions for instance I'm in an
industry I had a call today with a very
very very very big company let's just
say a few hundred billion dollars we had
a conference call today with them and
there
interested in what we're doing and I
brought up the idea to him on what I
want to do okay and and and I got it and
I was telling him all these ideas on
what I have going on what I'm thinking
about doing and I started questioning
certain things and he's like wow it
sounds like you know the market pretty
well and you know it seems like you kind
of Cydia what we were curious about this
because we were curious we asked this
question when we asked this question we
got this answer and when we asked this
question it made us research this and
this research brought us to another
question that led to another question
and we got the answer here and we also
looked at this year because we were
curious what could happen if we could do
with this
and as we got stuck because one question
we couldn't answer no if we figure this
and we contacted the right person then a
right to attorney who's 1200 dollars an
hour and then she introduced us to this
person and that person and we got this
answer right but we were curious and we
asked the right questions and so
collectively they're on the call now
we're meeting new york big meeting etc
etc then that could lead into a whole
different story because we're curious on
how we can make an industry that I'm a
part of that's probably the most boring
industry in the world the life insurance
industry that no one's paying attention
to but because we're curious we're
finding ways to disrupt this entire
industry that I am in love with that
people think Pat you're out of your mind
how do you love life insurance I love
what we do right but we were curious and
I'll get into a little bit more on that
later on in the video next ask the
question when you're thinking big why
not you and answer it I'm not just doing
this motivational video why not you why
shouldn't you win no no forget
motivation let's get logical why don't
you actually answer that why can't you
be somebody that can do something in
your business that's never been done
before why don't you answer it so give
the argument logically here's why not me
because I don't work hard enough you can
fix that stop being lazy well whatever
but because I'm not that good in self
you can learn sales so okay because I
don't know much about the product you
kill horn the product but why not you
because no one in my family has been
raped
what no one was in rich in Zuckerberg
family before he became who he is today
and nobody was in jobs jobs mom even
gave them up or adoption
yes you know stepfather you know so
whatever but so why not you make the
argument why don't you truly get into it
then give the other argument why not you
actually doing this why shouldn't you to
be why shouldn't you be the person and
say I'm a very smart person I love
people I actually like to make money to
make a difference in the world and you
know what I care for people and I have
some things I want to do if I get money
in my pocket would be good I'll do good
with it and I've got a big car and I am
talented and I thought that that then I
know the right people
boom that's why not you make both cases
as if you're an attorney representing
yourself one why not you meaning you
shouldn't be the person and the other
why not you meaning you should be the
person sell both of them and then see
which argument wins some tells me the
argument on this sides gonna win well
make that argument take a sheet of paper
make that argument why not you question
that a little bit who convinced you
can't do it who convinced you can be
part of a group of people I want so many
guys on YouTube that you know are even
some of these guys are considered
experts by big magazines and they've
written New York Times bestsellers and
they say some [ __ ] like oh you know
entrepreneurs are born
give me a damn break entrepreneurship
can be taught entrepreneurship is an
inspiration that comes from here for
some people that want to solve a bigger
problem
what do you mean entrepreneurship is
something you're born but I completely
disagree with that statement fully
disagree with that statement jump in 48
inches that's god-given ability you
can't do that entrepreneurship it is a
formula if you hang around other people
that think like this and you watch this
video and you watch all our value
tainment or some of the people that are
feeding the right type of content to you
and the right books you read your
imagination won't stop working because
the entrepreneur is numbers solving
problems how can I do it better faster
why can't you learn those doubts get
skills and the skill sets why can't you
you can so why not you
and don't let anybody convince you that
people who solve some big problems and
you know our big thinkers they have to
be born baby a big thing I'm here to
tell you you can figure out the formula
to thinking bigger
don't let them convince you that these
elite people sometimes I sit around my
friends who are worth money as well I'm
around these guys all the time so now
you know hey path you know come around
the meeting we're gonna go have some
party with these billionaires we're
gonna go any okay great I'm going with
these guys that you know I was always
special because from oh my gosh stop it
already when you almost lost everything
you did not think you were special none
of us do and we you know have our break
and we win you can do this wall next one
cut the fat cut the fat out of your life
let me tell you what I mean by cut the
fat if video games is not how you
planning on making your money cut the
fat if you have these three hobbies of
you playing badminton in Bakersfield or
you're playing ping pong go bowling
league or all this other stuff that's
requiring nine hours of your time cut
the fat if you got three girlfriends or
three boyfriends cut the fat if you
party at the nightclub three times a
week
cut the fans if you're going out they're
not taking life seriously and there's
two bad habits you have a vice that no
one knows about cut the fat it's holding
you back from thinking big stop it it's
not helping you out as much as you think
it is
cut the fat you know exactly what I'm
talking about I don't need to explain it
you know exactly what your time I think
about your thing about it right now that
thing you're thinking about cut it if
you want to think big hold you back it
ain't worth it I promise you whatever
thing that's giving you fulfillment it
ain't going to give you as much
fulfillment at stinking big I guarantee
you that part it ain't going to give you
as much fulfillment we've got to cut the
fat next is believers be around
believers now there's a part of this
that's environment but I'm talking about
believers that's believe it in your idea
you know this could actually happen what
if we could actually do this you know
what if we could actually pull this off
you need believers just like Justin
Bieber has his fans he calls them what
believers you need believers is what you
need you don't need no believers you
need believers this is what you need
okay next next this one's a little
technical this one's a little technical
so I'm going to try to explain it to you
but it's a little bit technical okay
momentum versus resistance momentum
versus resistance what is momentum
versus resistance big thinkers typically
have one of these two on their side one
of these two on their side no one goes
and takes the the the the normal way out
of being a big thinker right it's either
they get themselves caught up in the
momentum that's taking place in an
industry or they go absolutely against
resistance and they win they become a
hero you want some points I'll give you
some points for instance John F Kennedy
had momentum okay
MLK went against resistance now both of
them you know they were assassin it I'm
not telling you're gonna get
assassinated I'm telling you they both
did something that history favors both
of them JFK MLK JFK MLK JFK had momentum
MLK had resistance history books 2,000
years from now if our McGinn doesn't
happen and we're still around and our
great-great-great gegege Yankees are
around they're gonna know about JFK and
they're gonna know about resistance MLK
let me continue today on this side you
would have Elon Musk resistance why you
tell me the last time somebody broke
into the car market and gay Ford Toyota
you know shell Chevrolet giant all these
guys are run for their money you tell me
the last time someone did that who
Fisker Fisker failed
who else you're thinking about what was
the last time how many years no one has
you know must win against resistance let
me get this straight you're gonna create
electric cars and you're gonna take
market away from these bigger guys yes
how are you planning on doing that it's
resistance human against resistance the
other one PayPal resistance why no one's
gonna no one's gonna trust remember back
in the days when people didn't trust
buying things online
I don't trust giving my credit card
information remember those days today
how often they give you credit card
information online
they had resistance there was resistance
for it
Amazon was resistance you're gonna stop
selling books and bookstores no no no no
no borders no no no Barnes and no no no
resistance he proved you want almost run
out of business but you want okay now
momentum netflix's momentum Tomlinson
but that's also resistance no it's
momentum today I watched a movie what
movie did I tell you guys but I was very
impressed with account from with Ben
Affleck I'm not a Ben Affleck fan but
Ben Affleck did a Goodwill Hunting
phenomenal and accountants best movie
the year for me phenomenal movie right
right now you know what momentum is
today is not making movies is making
episodic series whatever you want to
call a house of cards or narcos or give
me some of them yeah all these other
things that are out there
that's momentum so people are making out
YouTube wants to do that you know you
got Roku you got Hulu you got net
everybody that's momenta people aren't
that momentum weight in mortgages in
2003 2004 mortgages were skyrocketing
everybody was getting into the [ __ ] AM
pick a payment loan that was momentum
you're riding the momentum but in 2008
Big Short the movie okay that was about
what Michael Lewis wrote it that was
about resistance same industry one way
is momentum the other one is resistance
they said no this is going to collapse
here's 300 million dollars you're out of
your mind
goldman sachs here's 300 million dollars
yes aha he's an idiot
resistance day one made a lot of money
millions of people lost their homes
resistance so what are you doing I'm in
the resistance game I'm at a life
insurance business I'm not in the
momentum business I'm in a resistance
business I'm in a resistance business
today I'm in a business that most people
say I'm not going to get into insurance
I'm in the business right now with a
financial industry regulation regulation
regular jamming resistance business but
here's what I do know about the
resistance business I do know 41% of
Americans don't have any life insurance
I do know 95 million adults that they
don't have life insurance I do know we
have the fewest amount of life insurance
agents we've ever had in America in a
long time nearly 50 years 50 years I
know what's happening in the industry
there is resistance in our industry I
know the industry
relax and multicultural agents I know
the industry is increasing in
multicultural clients that like to be
sold preferably by multicultural clients
I know the industry has resistance
because 25 year olds coming out of
college are now turned on by the life
insurance industry we're doing it and
we're very comfortable saying life
insurance our competitors are afraid
don't use the word people don't like it
I don't care if you don't like it I love
the industry resistance resistance I
know
people buy shoes cars homes clothes no
one buys life insurance life insurance
is soul its resistance I know it but I
see a massive opportunity with it
because I see exactly what's going on
with the industry
I chose resistance you don't have to
choose resistance there's momentum
there's a resistance you choose which
one you want to be a part of and by the
way I can go on right now VR virtual
reality is what moments the hot bank hot
thing virtual reality right you know you
got office you got defense so you can
put it up the way you want to put it up
but virtual you got the offense defense
you know I already covered a bunch of
these things that I have here
momentum resistance how is your business
going to be part of either one of these
things is it going to be momentum or
it's going to be resistance big thinkers
figure one of these two out you know
what if we do this what if this thing
gets like this because there's momentum
you know what there's so many problems
in our industry what if we actually
solve it we're heroes resistance which
one do you want big thinker chooses one
of these to make a list of it in your
field in your company in your industry
in your profession you've chosen to be
part of which don't you want to be part
of you can choose either
I chose resistance many choose momentum
you can choose your own okay
let me continue neck next look where no
one's looking look where no one's
looking I've said there's so many times
you go to a bar men when you go to a bar
who is everybody looking at at that bar
or nightclub who how to scroll on the
club and everyone knows which one it's a
girl in the green dress everyone's
checking a rod and you suggest was
around her everybody you know what your
odds are if there's five hundred men and
on nightclub there's one over it's one
to five hundred know what that
percentages are point two percent chance
she's going to
say yes do you want those kind of odds
you don't want those kinds of odds go
find the eight and look what happens
with the 8 the 8 has only 30 men looking
at her you're one of them you got 3%
chance it's higher chances go look at
places that no one's looking at and see
who's more interesting it's not always
the sexiest thing on the outside that's
the best company to be a part of our the
best industry to be part of sometime
it's where no one's looking everyone's
going here you go here everybody and
their mothers is joining this incredible
next movement that's going to be the
revolution of Tata that's great let them
go you go look at something almost
looking at massive opportunity blue
ocean red ocean shark-infested market
everyone's biting killing each other
there's only a couple sharks you're
dealing with you can actually negotiate
with those sharks they listen I got a
big bad you want to share this yeah
here's a bite for yours buy from you
real cool Pepsi coke big market you take
some I'll take some are we cool we're
cool but only to everybody else wants to
fight for wine everybody else wants to
fight for you no beer look dude
what do you want you're a big shark I'm
a big shark yeah going to food I'll give
you some here's your's all right let's
go do it go where no one's looking at oh
so much easier next deliberately forbid
conventional solutions stop thinking
about the conventional way of doing
things no you got to be out-of-the-box
thinker you got to be out of the box and
you can't think about every single way
everybody else wants to solve that
problem
drop conventional thinking big thinkers
kind of look at different ways they
stick to it and they don't constantly
change all the time because once
something works you stick to it and then
when you have to make certain
adjustments or adapting all that other
you don't make overhauls because we make
overhauls man it it hurts you but you
make adjustments some say Tiger Woods
could have beaten Jack Nicklaus
Nicholas's record of the most Masters if
he wouldn't have dramatically changed
his swing when he did that took his game
back to three years and and he got hurt
because it was a major shift and I know
people say didn't need the back all this
other stuff but he could have one more
masters because it was too dramatic of a
shift there's a lot of motivational
speakers I like to say you know look
what Tiger did and he made a shift even
in his crew I get it
probably validates an argument that
person's trying to make at that time but
sometimes when something works working
but while you're going to your game plan
try all the other conventional thinking
unconventional way of solving that
problem that that industry or company or
the product is facing so what do you do
now let's just say you have your plan in
place what do you do now now you got to
work backwards so think big where I see
myself in ten years from now this
business in this company in this
industry put a 10-year plan how about
five years then three then one then six
then three months and today put a
one-two-three plan together did I need
to focus on one dish to this three this
everything needs to be tied to a number
why because big thinking has to do with
what so first thing I said math so
everything is math you notice numbers
here it's math
put your numbers together start thinking
bigger and next thing you know you'll
actually will say you know what this big
thinking stuff is not as difficult as I
thought it was but I hope you take this
whole message very seriously on how to
think big and I wanted to give it to you
in a way that most people you know the
typical traditional things you read on
magazines that set goals you know do
this I want to give you in a complete
different way of thinking about bigger
that some of the other outlets don't
talk about but I my challenge to you is
don't make this about you make it about
a bigger cause the world is depending on
you to think big and solve problems
today more than ever and like I said
earlier it is easier today the thing
bigger than ever before Mari let me get
my pillow here by the way some of you
guys smarter you wanted me to send a
message to you guys and thank you guys
for the most incredible heartfelt
messages you guys been sending him about
street team mario is so thankful about
all and since love you if you haven't
seen him don't worry about it but
Mario's been getting a lot of love from
people that watch the street and Paul
you're part of that as well so I got to
throw a Yenta to you're part of that as
well they're trying to figure it out see
what's going to happen with street team
we're going to be launching a lot of new
stuff here soon so stay tuned if you
haven't subscribed to value tainment yet
please do so our goal is to get to
quarter million subs right a hundred
some thousand subs now our goal is to
get to
quarter million subs by June 1st of next
year this is a channel that many say
it's the number one channel for
entrepreneurs on YouTube we'd love to
for you to test it out against anybody
else at that that gives you the best
how-to for entrepreneurship without
asking for eight thousand dollars or six
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
or five thousand dollars free content
that we have here we want to say
sometimes videos say that again at the
contest video that's right we got a ton
of them by the way for some of you guys
when we did a hundred thousand if you
haven't posted your video yet October
25th its elastic to post your video we
already have a ton of people that are
posted at Mario's put the top 15 or 16
playlists that you can see just go on
YouTube and type and why I love value
taming you'll see a bunch of people that
have submitted their videos we're going
to choose three of them where you're
flying here to Dallas Texas and you and
I will get some one-on-one time for 3
hours for me to do the business planning
with you for your business in 2017 but
only three of you will be chosen to come
here and spend some time with us so if
you haven't submitted it yet you can
always email Mario why don't I give them
your email marketing at Patrick payday
me dr. Paul let's put that email address
here marketing at Patrick medical comm
he'll get back to you still works
marketing at Patrick we calm and if you
got any questions about that but so
today on how to think big comment on the
bottom questions thoughts thanks for
watching everybody
take care
you